qu'est ce que ça représente cet endroit
pour vous mais ça représente toute mon
enfance un parce que
toute petite chose faut dire qu'on
habitait au sein des habitations des
plantations donc ça a été
pour moi une heure de jeu une aire de
jeu pendant des années un nous les
enfants pourront s'amuser à venir jouer
au tour ou même alain tur du champs de
bananes et aussi goûter
ils mangeaient les bananes qui était mûr
sur les au niveau des régimes
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous
retournée comme souvenirs à part ses
terrains de jeu main a posteriori
aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui par
rapport
par rapport à l' enquête qui a commencé
concernant les empoisonnements
l'empoisonnement des ouvriers agricoles
de rien c'est ce que montre la surface 1
quand on est enfant n'est pas toujours
conscients les choses et il ya plein de
choses qui me reviennent en mémoire
puisque jeunes accompagnés pas mes
parents mais souvent on leur amener leur
gamelle en mi-journée donc au fait de ce
jeu met à pied bien sûr ont traversé
tous ces chants et on n'était pas
conscient à l'époque de la gravité des
produits que les pins se met au niveau
des champs et quand j'ai commencé à
grandir j'ai remarqué que
la santé de mes parents surtout
particulier de ma mère qui décède à
l'âge de 53 ans des cancers donc ça
sentait s'affaiblissait de jour en jour
et quand je la voyais est arrivé le soir
j'avais l'impression qu'on l'avait
trompée dans une friteuse électrique
tellement qu'elle était recouvert de
tout ce produit doc elle ne se met pas
elle même est produit le produit mais
elle était juste après la personne le
monsieur qui répandait et voilà qui
fondait puisqu'elle était obligé de
bastille et chaque régime et elle était
juste sous les bras de cette personne
donc tout ce produit vous tombez sur et
et est une chose aussi du mal qui m'a
vraiment interpellé un bon là avec du
recul on apprend mieux l arrivée avec
tous ces vêtements la grille cellule
parce que c'était du grand moxon et le
gramoxone c'était comme si c'était de
l'huile et quand elle arrivait se
dépêcher de se déshabiller de mettre ses
vêtements a trompé à pain et elle nous
est surtout ne pas mélanger toutes les
lectures surtout qu'on avait jamais vos
petits fois du temps au bébé nu il peut
dire que votre maman elle avait
conscience
absolument elle avait conduit dont
j'aimais bien le bien longtemps après
quand elle a commencé à être malade à
faire des surtout à faire à faire des
pauses pour se répéter parce qu'elle a
eu des fausses couches répété pendant
des années
entre mon petit frère et moi y'a une
différence de 11 ans donc pendant des
années elle a eu des fausses couches
suite à des chutes répétées avec les
régimes de bananes sur la tête
papa aussi elle avait aussi des
évanouissements par rapport à ces
produits donc se faisait soigner par
j'espère que je dois le dire un peu
doctorat audi qui a soigné beaucoup
d'ouvriers agricoles selon robert et
qu'il faisait comprendre que ce produit
était très très néfaste pour sa santé
vous parlez de régime de régimes de
bananes oui cela fait combien de régimes
de bananes à chaque fois est ce qu'elle
devait porter et combien par jour alors
à ma connaissance
elle portait deux sur la tête parce que
la veine très elle mettait un régime de
chaque côté donc
elle avait
elle devait minimum transporté 120
région si ma mémoire est bonne sans les
régions et par jour bonjour et là lors
de mon enquête 1 beta simon dia mais nos
maris bon tu encore loin du compte en
parce que c'était deux régimes de chaque
côté et l'autre régime au milieu ou
sinon de régime sur la tête et l'autre
régime à la main et il fallait
transporter 135 régime par jour c'était
l'exigence c'était l'exigence et l exige
et d'après par rapport à chaque
plantations encore dimanche dernier on
était dans le nom c'était 165 par jour
donc en fonction de l'habitation de
voilà mais c'était entre 5 à la main sur
la tête sous la côte d'azur pas aujourd
hui sur la tête c'est à dire est une
chose que j'ai aussi que qualitativement
expliqué je pense que ma mort mais pas
de certaines choses que chaque régime de
bananes devait fait entre 30 30 et 35 kg
donc j'ai fait une petite moyenne quand
on a 90 kg sur la tête
évidemment il y avait des chutes voilà
et
et aussi il ya quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup marqué elle me disait maman
entre les les rangées de bananier il ya
un espace on appelle c'est sion je crois
donc le site est tellement la hausse par
rapport à chaque habitation avaient
leurs spécificités mais par endroits
c'était tellement lange
elle avait du mal à descendre et
remonter avec le poids sur la tête de la
challenge en fait et quand elle est là
l'enjamber cécillon effectivement le
plus souvent soit il y avait des chutes
mais tu as tu me disais c'est peut-être
parce que les jeux faisait beaucoup
d'enfants auparavant elle sentait qu'il
y avait une descente de matrix et cetera
donc c'était très douloureux doux d'où
l'importance de décommander fausse
couche a répété tous et tous ces maux
toutes ces difficultés est ce que l
le est-ce que votre maman votantes qui
ont aussi travailleur avanade on en
parlait aux patrons aux békés et
quelle a été sa réaction ben en parler
l'on en parle et non parce que donnent
tant qu'homme c'est leur poser la
question ça m'a toujours interpellé et
me disais bon mari parce qu'on m'appelle
marie quand on doit nous et on lui dise
aux enfants mais on va travailler un si
bien qu' il ya une tatie jamais vu maman
s'arrêter congé maladie j'ai pas que je
connais pas ça et j'ai une pratique il
me disait mais oui c'était normal parce
que quand elle c'était dans une tactique
est tombée la veille côtes cassées et
est obligé d'aller travailler parce que
dans le temps pour payer il fallait
déposer l'arrêt maladie à la fin de la
les docks si vous êtes arrêté pendant
quinze jours
il faut attendre 15 jours pour déposer
là et pendant l'épisode vous travaillez
pas il ya des bouches à nourrir
donc les mêmes malades et aller
travailler qui veut dire que par exemple
les femmes qui devait enjamber les
sillons mieux et qui tombaient par
exemple se blesser ben ça relevait puis
à se serrer les dents elle se remettait
au travail et ma mère ma maman sinon
elles sont pas payés c'est la journée
n'est pas finie parce que ma maman ce
qui était très dur et c'est vrai que ça
excuse moi elle faisait et faisait sa
journée et quand les autres il y en a
qui était plus homogène plus faibles
entre guillemets donc à devrait finir sa
journée avait une telle solidarité entre
ces femmes et elles devaient aller
comme on dit terminée la tâche de
l'autre en quoi est ce qu'elle est et
papilles donc il y avait une solidarité
entre les femmes d'où je sais pas sur
toutes les habitations mais l'habitation
au moulin à eau où les femmes sont très
bas donc celle qui n'avait pas terminé
il fallait aider les autres thèmes ni
l'autre s'ils n'étaient pas payés
[Musique]